so let's talk about the difference in
the differences between Europe and
America so obviously you've been
spending years in Britain and now you're
spending an increasing amount of time
America what's the attraction of America
and what sort of the outsider's view of
America see we're so you know we hear
sort of the fish that are living in the
in the sea and can't see the water at
all but what what does America look like
from the outside to everybody else well
it's a dangerous question for me to
answer Ben because I'm always worried
about repeating the mistake of Alexander
solzhenitz and he came here very
welcomed people loved him and then he
started criticizing America and it was
like you know people got upset right so
that's why I came to Britain where they
love being criticized by Outsiders and I
talk there but look from there every
time I come here I'm actually humbled by
my own ignorance about this country my
number one takeaway every single time I
go to different places is this isn't a
country it's it's a group of countries
and people with different religions
Different World Views and it kind of
explains a lot of the political
Dimensions I think because you've got
people who've got a completely different
set of values attempting to coexist in
one space and it sort of explains I
think why the debates are raging as hard
as they are the attraction of America
it's the ambition it's the drive it's
the the positive optimism the ability to
think into the future and to think you
know what I want to build things I want
to do things that's always been my
mindset and I've never felt that
anywhere in any part of the world as
free as I do here because when you say
you know I want to do this in America
everyone's like go for it how can I help
how can I get involved it's not always
the case in other countries so yeah I I
totally agree with you that as America
fragment as it becomes more diverse not
in terms of race but but more in terms
of ideology as that happens the United
States our future looks a lot more like
the EU current meaning like kind of
falling apart than it does like it has
historically like the idea of a strong
centralized government presiding over a
unitary state it actually looks more in
some ways like it did at the very
beginning which was a bunch of separate
states with very separate State
identities and then you have a few
things that you sort of agree on at the
top level but one of the big problems
that we have here is that the federal
government is now so strong is the most
strong body in the history of humanity
actually that when when you have the
strongest centralized government in the
history of humanity because we are a
more powerful government than the
government of China China is much more
centralized but whale is powerful in
terms of just Global power and ability
to project and economics when you have
that heavy a a government sitting atop a
set of stilts essentially and that set
of stilts is the notion that we all you
know share something then eventually it
feels like it's going to either break
the stilts and crush or you're going to
have to unload the top of the the top of
that pyramid if we're going to mix out
all of our metaphors here 100 you know
as I say traveling around I've been to
East Coast West Coast I spent some time
in Salt Lake City a few days ago uh my
sense I I understood much better now
seeing more of America why the idea that
things should be decided at the local
level as much as possible is such a
powerful idea here and the way that it
maybe isn't in other places because of
the genuine diversity of the country so
I get that argument a lot more now and
the more America I see them why I'm
persuaded by that view you're thinking a
lot in terms of family and as you're
traveling around the United States you
were saying off the air that religious
community has become kind of more
interesting to you so you're personally
agnostic but you've noticed that
religious communities are bringing
something to the table so let's talk
about your religious worldview what
makes you an agnostic as opposed to a
religious believer who just has doubts
meaning like